a Donald Trump speech writer David
Sorenson has resigned over allegations
that he abused his ex-wife during their
marriage
Sorensen's ex-wife says that Sorenson
once drove a car over her foot a once
put a cigarette out on her hand and much
more and this now makes Sorensen the
second wife beating resignation by a
trump staffer only in the last week of
2018 you'll remember that last week we
talked on the bonus show about the
resignation of Trump Secretary atra
staff secretary Rob Porter who had
multiple credible accusations of
wife-beating against him from multiple
ex-wives
he's currently dating Donald Trump's
communications director hope Hicks which
raises a whole other series of questions
about concerns around the resignation so
a few different issues to talk about
right first is yeah there seems to be a
consistent lack of the good people that
Trump ran on hiring right Trump ran on
the promise that he would be hiring the
best people first and foremost it's not
happening secondly there are questions
about the elegant John Kelly Trump's
chief of staff who's not seeming quite
so elegant anymore since it's clear that
Kelly knew about the allegations against
Rob Porter for a while
he knew that Rob Porter was not
eventually going to be able to get a
permanent security clearance yet he
still allowed Rob Porter to keep working
at the White House and I believe that
John Kelly should resign at this point I
think that there is absolutely no
justification for Kelly staying on but
let's get to the big picture the
wife-beating staffers thing is not
really that surprising right the
President himself has more than a dozen
allegations against him one of trumps
ex-wives says that Trump raped her
repeatedly while they were married and
Trump is accused of raping a kid a girl
who was 13 years old at the time why on
earth would we expect that staffers
would be held to a higher standard than
Trump other than the hypocrisy that
we've seen from Trump on so many issues
this
is just not a big deal within the White
House unless it becomes a PR problem
right and now
Kellyanne Conway is being praised
because she says I have no reason not to
believe Rob Porter's accusers well you
have no reason not to believe them but
you've been working in the White House
the entire time that all of this stuff
was swirling and for a guy with more
than a dozen sexual assault allegations
against him so some people are holding
Kellyanne Conway up as some kind of hero
because she says she believes the
accusers you're working for a guy who
has more than a dozen accusations
against them do you not believe any of
those women and and at this point it's
more a question of who in the Trump
administration isn't a horrible person
right and I do want to make one last
thing clear because I think this is an
important thing to distinguish I don't
think that Trump should be
I don't believe Trump shouldn't be
president because of this stuff I think
he shouldn't be president because he's
incompetent and his policies are
terrible and he's in way over his head
but the fact that he's morally so
disgusting and his staff is disgusting
that it exposes the hypocrisy of the
so-called Values Voters that he appealed
to with some degree of success during
the election but it's the incompetence
and the policy that make him unfit to be
President of the United States this
stuff just makes him not a good person
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad